I would never go hunting not there's no
way that I would ever go hunting this is
like heaven look at all this my name is
Merle and I'm a vegan I'm vegan for
environmental reasons but I'm also a
pretty hardcore animal lover I was in
Montreal and there were these people
there called anonymous and they were
screening factory footage in like a town
square and I caught myself just like
staring at the TV and someone came up to
me was like hey if you're interested at
all try going vegan for 30 days and so I
did and I felt really good and after
that I was just like I think I'm done I
don't think I want to be handcuffed to
anybody for 24 hours
let alone a person that I've never met
and knowing you guys I feel like this is
gonna be like a hardcore person that
like comes in wearing pigskin or
something I'm nervous
hello how's it going I'm Kelsey rose
nice to meet you
my name is Kelsey rose I started eating
meat because I grew up in Tokyo and so
we ate a lot of fish a lot of chick in
there but I also do hunt I'm a big
hunter so I've grown up hunting with my
dad after you have finished your hunt
you have to feel dressed all the animals
which means that you need to basically
remove the meat from the rest of the
animal so when you feel a dress it dove
you start with the head and you tear the
head off and then you go to the wings
and you tear them you tear a mountain
there's like a snap so you know that
they've like been removed out and then
with your fingers you go into the
breastbone and you basically rip it
apart and then you
have your your breast meat let's do it I
don't even know how to work handcuffs I
think that's a good this is going great
yeah girl even when you're handcuffed LA
traffic sucks always especially Zoe got
me we're gonna talk to the butcher and
see what came in fresh today and what
we're gonna see where all the magic
happens guys I'll go into a garden with
you yeah that seems like a fair
trade-off know where meat comes from and
and getting it from a store that does
kill them humanely and uses all parts of
the animal is super important to me I
just have to say like the phrase killed
humanely is a little bit of a naughty
one yes but if you are gonna kill an
animal kill it the most humane way okay
not there we go they can settle on that
in exchange for going to the butchery we
are now going to get to the ingredients
for what I'm gonna make for dinner at an
artisanal
mainstream grocery stores all right here
we go
correction okay great my sister
[Music]
hello again so we went for a grocery run
mushrooms and all basically all
vegetables like there's just so many
potatoes my question really is what
she's how she's gonna feed me with
nutritional yeast seasoning this is the
cheese sauce quote-unquote cheese sauce
for the vegan mac and cheese let me just
say like I would not make this for
myself every day I this is a lot of
effort
looks like we're eating food from the
famine
hey there we go we've reached the meat
portion so here we go my moment to shine
I like to smear it in duck fat this
might look really gross to some people
oh yeah so instead of making this which
is a beautiful thick cut bacon or make
this it could be bacon it's really
difficult to eat in handcuffs gonna do
this so really yummy
I'm very impressed they do have like a
bacon texture they kind of have the fat
from the chitara it totally like and
there's a good crunch to it so I'm very
I've learned I've learned a new recipe
today and I will say even those
magnitudes taken hours it is really good
[Music]
this is like horrifying and like so sad
at the same time they're still
struggling as they are dunked upside
down in cases like these people will
have like sadistic points of view
because like I think of everybody if
they wanted to eat me how to go hunt
they're on me a lot of people probably
wouldn't eat me but because we've
created an industry where they literally
factory farm and they like like plump
them up with steroids I can anything
pigs are shackled suspended everywhere
and immersed in scalding tanks to remove
their person also like one thing I'll
say is like I did stop eating meat
because I don't like me like I love yeah
meat I don't it's not something I did
like because I was like I think I'll
just yeah this is an easy thing to do
I'll stop eating this thing I love but
for me it's like it's just my choice
right and I can still want I can still
desire meet occasionally like I've used
to [ __ ] love steak I used to eat
lobster like I love that [ __ ] but this
is more important to me so that's why I
stopped Oh gross I'm really glad we ate
dinner before we watch this I there's a
kind of an art to this okay and we have
a super fun day plan for tomorrow that's
both half vegan half me eater so
whatever
[Music]
we're out of shooting range then we're
gonna shoot this eat today I think the
camera is making it better okay now that
we're on handcuffs I can be honest
wearing the Hat
I'm feeling acting really confident but
in reality I am absolutely terrified to
be shooting any gun right now I don't
like guns I don't like the kickback I am
a nervous that I'm not gonna hit
anything and I am completely and totally
out of my comfort zone but I'm just
gonna do it look at my little girl my
little vegan
she looks pretty natural not gonna lie
and now it's loaded so proud of her what
do you think I gotta admit that was so
fun I'm like all fired up right now and
I will probably do this and she kicked
butt you gotta love it like actually hit
more than once so I'm feeling pretty
good about myself right now
that's like do a cartwheel or something
once I put the gun out with the gun I'm
really proud because it's nice to have
like another badass woman - yeah women
holding it down I'm gonna feel pretty
close range the range oh yeah
all right ready for another ground no I
think my cheek needs a rest okay
so my girl morale has been so
open-minded and I'm so happy because not
a lot of vegans a lot of people would be
down to go to a shooting range I know
we're not hunting but uh oh my god she
made yeah but she is kicking butt and I
appreciate going through this process
with someone who is open-minded and
who's down to kind of see how I live my
life as I am open to see how she lives
her so I'm pretty stoked it's been a
really good day I I kind of don't want
this 24 hours to end maybe we can hang
out not handcuffed yeah just a
suggestion
wow-wow-wow a crazy 24 hours it has been
I think the biggest surprise was that
Kelsey and I actually had much more in
common than we ever thought we would
even though she's a mediator even though
she's a hunter and after the challenge I
have no interest in becoming a hunter or
eating meat again I will say that she
did show me a way of consuming meat that
I think was more responsible and more
honest the fact that she hunts her own
meat and she sees she sees the thing
that dies for her and she sees it up
close and she you know cleans it herself
and does the whole thing I actually have
respect for that and even though it's
not how I choose to eat and I don't
necessarily think that that might be a
sustainable model for everyone
chickens
me I do think it's something for more
people to consider and at the end of the
day she's completely right she knows
where her meat comes from she goes out
of her way to spend a little more to eat
meat that's healthy and eat meat that
ideally has had a better life so our
common enemy is factory farming and even
though we have two totally different
ways of confronting it I'd say that
we're both doing our part in one way or
another
[Music]
[Music]